former attorney general of nevada and  current nevada state senator catherine  cortez-masto is speaking now let's  listen in  conducting canvassing and even  contesting  the results and they are right  arizona has one of the most transparent  election processes  in the country with built-in  accountability starting  with eternal auditing we have heard  unfounded allegations that voting  machines in arizona and elsewhere  somehow changed vote tallies or somehow  improperly rejected ballots while  claiming  to accept them these allegations  all ignore the fact that arizona  counties  conducted ballot audits by hand  to double check the machine counts and  these audits found  no widespread fraud or irregularities  maricopa county the county where the  more than 60 percent  of the state population resides  conducted a post  election hand count audit in the week  after  the election which showed hearing there  from senator master will have much more  on 8 news now at 6